while i was working for an outside sales
organization i got the entrepreneurial
itch like i want to run my own business
because i was working for a company that
when i started they gave me a car
a laptop and a phone and a credit card
all right
go build and maintain your market
are you kidding me
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opwest hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel and in media
partnership with ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders i have with us today carson tate
carson serves as a consultant and
executive coach to executives at fortune
500 companies including but not limited
to abv deloitte fedex johnson johnson
craft heinz synchrony and wells fargo
she's the author of work simply
embracing the power of your personal
productivity style penguin portfolio
2015 and own it love it make it work how
to make any job your dream job mcgraw
hill 2020 reviews have been including in
top tier business media including
bloomberg business week business insider
cbs money watch fast company forbes
harvard business review blog the new
york times usa today working mother and
more carson is also the creator of the
productivity style assessment a
professional tool featured in harvard
business reviews 2017 guide to being
more productive
parson tate welcome to 20 minute leaders
how are you i'm doing well michael how
are you
i'm doing great thank you so much for
joining me today i'm really really
excited to chat with you and i know how
busy you are so i really really
appreciate it but you know the world
that we're living in is completely crazy
and i'm i don't know really how to make
sense of it but hopefully in the in the
next 20 minutes or so i'll be able to do
it properly tell me a little bit about
your own journey specifically thinking
about you know employer engagement the
workforce the world that we're living in
now and and working simply and not in a
complicated way
so employee engagement is probably on
everyone's mind because what you're
seeing and what i'm seeing people are
quitting left and right they're quitting
their jobs because it's not fulfilling
they don't enjoy it and maybe they're
overwhelmed over stretched covet has
been challenging for most folks a lot of
folks have had existential crisis
wondering is this all there is to work
in life
and so when you think about engagement
it's personal
there's no one-size-fits-all it's about
what you need to be engaged and
fulfilled and you're accountable for
making it happen we're going to
outsource your engagement this is about
ownership
and so what does that actually mean what
does that mean ownership
so it means two things one it means
recognizing that you do actually have
power in the relationship with your
employer so i think about it as a social
contract so just like you have friends
where there's give and take
there's the same thing in the
relationship with your employer so you
bring skills
they need to drive revenue
which means you've got power in this
relationship and it's recognizing that
for your business to be successful they
need you and you also need them in terms
of compensation the second piece is that
clarity what do you need to be engaged
how do you want to be recognized or
rewarded how do you want to grow in your
career what are your strengths how do
you define meaning and purpose and work
is this a new concept this idea that we
have power
within our relationship with our
employer that we provide value that we
that that we are an important part of
the success of the organization we're in
i wouldn't say it's new
i don't think it's been fully embraced
so now more than any period of time in
history it is an employee's market it is
your opportunity to co-create with your
employer what you want and need i think
so often we have felt beholden to our
employers we have to do everything in
order to keep our jobs that's not the
situation now you we need you to be
engaged if i'm your employer because
productivity goes up but also
there's a talent shortage i need you i
need highly talented folks and i want to
retain them
right
and so what is this relationship
actually look like today
and from your perspective and i'd love
to hear a little bit about your
background as well and and how you
ventured into this into this world of
thinking so that you know i can look for
myself and for my friends and colleagues
how do we navigate this more complicated
situation now in the workforce
so i'll start with background and then
i'll give you a framework so
i hated my job i had a job it was
terrible i was in sales and outside
sales making cold sales calls i had a
miserable boss and i was tired of just
waking up every day dreading going to
work and i thought it was all my boss's
problem and my company's problem and i
had a conversation with my college
cross-country coach who helped me
reframe
and realized that the only person you
can change is yourself
so if the situation you're in isn't
working
you're not going to change your
micromanaging boss you're not
going to change the work you can change
your relationship to it so that was my
first experience of how do you take
ownership for what you need i wanted to
learn and grow so i found someone who
was great at sales in the organization
shadowed and let him mentor me then i
wanted to figure out meaning and purpose
and did some work around what's the
purpose of this work so that was my
first experience of
maybe there's more to this maybe it's
not only my employer's job
then as i started working with our
clients at working simply and realizing
that the traditional engagement method
so you're gonna pay me more we're gonna
have a ping pong table all these great
benefits and bonuses and nap rooms
that's a piece of it we all want it but
that's not enough to engage me no
so that's where i realized it's five
essentials for professional fulfillment
so recognition and reward
using your strengths
having really strong relationships
having a career plan where you can
develop and grow in your career and
discerning the meaning and purpose in
your work those are the five
fundamentals that are required for all
of us to connect and find our work more
fulfilling and engaging
so all those sound amazing how do we
actually go about doing them because
we're so occupied with the day-to-day
you know stress whether it's at home
whether it's at work uh you know there
is uncertainty in the world especially
during this time and and you're
mentioning it it is in an employees
market but how do we go about even
trying to figure out a lot of those deep
questions ourselves
so it's going to take some reflection
and it's also going to take hopefully
someone who can help you with that
process so to figure out how you want to
be recognized and this is truly about
being recognized a thank you for
performance and acknowledgement of hard
work think about your best day at work
what was your best day at work ever
what did you do
so tell me about your best day at work
my best day at work was probably
my first day at my internship at 17.
okay what made it the best day
i came into what i discovered to be a an
office where there were three people
sitting there i was given the laptop and
i had to work and i didn't have homework
i wasn't in school i got to create stuff
myself which was a crazy responsibility
oh so it's about creating something
yourself
so that's what led you okay did you
receive any did anybody tell you
anything during the day with what you
created was good or needed work or
improvement
i didn't get much feedback but i got but
the autonomy that i had and the fact
that i didn't constantly need to check
in with somebody
and that that felt very empowering
so you have two
two really good examples of things that
you want you need some autonomy and the
opportunity to create so knowing that
how in your current job can we look for
more opportunities for you to create and
find more autonomy and so to do that
we've got to connect those two to the
goals and objectives of the company so
let's say one of your goals and
objectives in your current company is to
increase sales
how does you
be more creative in a product or in
solving problems faster allow us to
achieve that goal faster or exceed it
that's how you want to create that but
you have to have that conversation with
your manager
but when you connect it to the goal that
strategic goal what's in it for them
you're now co-creating a situation where
you thrive and they thrive
that makes a lot of sense and obviously
that requires also that your manager and
the chain of sort of the chain of
leadership are also cognizant of those
of those kpis of the organization as a
whole and of the team as a whole right
because you know in today's world with
organizations that have uh that have a
very big range of of responsibilities it
can get pretty confusing
i would expect for your manager to know
their goals and objectives and kpis
that's the basic
requirement of a leader
okay perfect so so so that so we're
actually going into this into this
conversation with the assumption that uh
that that we're working in a place where
the people that are above us in the
chain of leadership they understand the
goal and perhaps if we're if they're not
then maybe we're in the wrong place
yes
so clarity of goals and objectives to
drive performance for me are like that's
a basic yes and so we're going to work
off the assumption your manager knows
what their goals and objectives are to
achieve the strategic priorities of the
company and you know what they are and
to do more of the work that you enjoy
you're connecting what you do well what
you want more of
to those goals and how it helps the
company achieve those goals
right so with your with the insights
that you've had and with the different
case studies and you know what how what
is your day-to-day life what do you
actually do what do i actually do yeah
yeah so uh there is always an element of
some type of creation or writing so
writing something for a publication
i was creating a new training program
for hybrid leadership this morning for a
client i just got off a coaching call
with another client and this afternoon i
have another coaching call and a couple
of sales calls
so it's a variety throughout the day
which i love so one thing that keeps me
excited is is a different type of work
day where there's different things to do
and challenging different parts of my
brain
okay and so what if somebody has trouble
discovering those elements like the
questions that you asked me what what
what if there's it's a problem because
it's not always clear what we actually
want and what we're actually motivated
by especially if somebody feels they're
stumped at work and they're not sure if
it's because of their manager if it's
because of themselves or if it's because
of the actual job that they're doing
so i have a to help i have a couple of
different
checklists and assessments
in my book own it love it make it work
because exactly this point michael this
can be really really hard to do so there
are a series of questions where you
answer yes and no a series of questions
where you rank yes i have this i want
more of it to help you discern the other
place i typically tell folks to go is if
they have any type of feedback
from their current job a previous job
helping you denote strengths areas for
growth the impact that you've had is
always a great place to check
right and so once we go through this
process i'm imagining this is also an
irritative process it's not one that we
do now it's gonna end next week and then
we're good for the next two years right
it's something that we keep having to to
check within ourselves
absolutely because you're growing and
developing and changing along the way so
it is an iterative process but i would
suggest that you start at one place so
if you don't feel seen and valued then
let's focus on that recognition if you
don't believe that you have the
relationships that you need to advance
in your career or just that sense of
community at work let's focus on
building relationships so it's one
incremental piece at a time to create
that job that's fulfilling and engaging
for you
that makes a lot of sense tell me a
little bit about your own upbringing and
how you even got to think about this
world of of you know the workforce
employer engagement and how we can be
better
yes so i started my career in human
resources so in corporate human
resources so which is about developing
people and really helping people be
their best selves which i really enjoyed
and then i went into outside sales and
that's where i realized there was an
intersection between engagement with
your work
and performance and it the sales folks
who were the highest performing were the
ones that really enjoyed their work the
most and they're pretty effective and
efficient great had great technical
skills
but the work had value and meaning for
them and so while i was working for an
outside sales organization i got the
entrepreneurial itch like i want to run
my own business because i was working
for a company that when i started they
gave me a car a laptop and a phone and a
credit card all right
go build and maintain your market
are you kidding me it must be like your
first day i think it was very similar
like i have all this autonomy and you
just want me to go i am all in on this
it was fantastic
and that really was the opening to be an
entrepreneur so i started coaching and
helping colleagues be more effective in
their job and started working simply
over 10 years ago
i love it and if you had to choose a few
words for yourself or if i would ask
anybody that you're coaching or working
with how would they describe carson
thoughtful
focused
and kind
thoughtful focused and kind of carson
thank you so so much i really appreciate
the time i appreciate the insight i'm
going to take a lot of this for myself
and i'm going to be sharing this with a
lot of my friends and then you hear this
as well so thank you very very much for
your insights and stay safe and stay
healthy
thanks thank you michael
[Music]